foreign
do you spend more money on Virtual
fashion and video games than you do on
physical clothes
about a third of all teenage gamers in
America do
you think the government is actually run
by a secret cabal of demon worshiping
perverts
about 50 million people do
these numbers sound crazy to you
because they are but they're also a sign
of things to come
World feels like a pretty insane place
right now
if you spend any time on the internet at
all you can probably tell that people
think it's going to get a lot worse
now that may be the case
but this feeling is why I believe that
we're going to see a rise in social
unrest in the coming decades
and that it's going to come from a
surprising place
video games
now before you think is this going to be
another talk linking video games to
violence sorry to disappoint you that's
been proven conclusively wrong and that
is really old thinking
but what I am going to argue is that
video games are going to become the
platform through which tomorrow's social
battles will be fought and the source of
recruitment for some of the strangest
and possibly most impactful social
movements of the future
I like to call these video game cults
sounds kind of scary I admit but I hope
to show how they might also be used as a
tool
to cause some serious hope
now this is all just my personal opinion
but I started thinking about this a few
years ago after I heard a very
interesting story while working in the
Gulf
the story was about Hassan IBN Sabha
charismatic young preacher who lived
about a thousand years ago in an age
full of drama conflict and social change
Hassan became famous for creating the
order of Assassins a fanatically devoted
group of young men known as the fedain
those who sacrificed themselves
his men were so devoted to him that the
legend goes they would throw themselves
from the rafters to their death at his
command actually this is where we get
the expression a leap of faith from
just got me thinking why would someone
do this
what could convince someone
so fervently to believe in something
that they would welcome their own death
the answer
is 11th century virtual reality
see Hassan had cultivated a myth that he
could send people to heaven and bring
them back again without actually having
to die and of course he didn't actually
have this power but before a mission The
Story Goes he would dose his soldiers
with massive amounts of hash
their enemies actually call them the
hashashin which is also where we get the
word Assassin from
this would knock them out and then he
would lower them down into a secret
garden he had built behind his Mountain
Fortress designed to look exactly like a
replica of Heaven
waking up in the simulated Paradise his
men would Gorge themselves and all the
things they had been denied in life
then after a night of ecstasy they would
awaken back in their Barracks convince
of Hassan's Powers eager to fulfill his
suicide missions in order to return to
Heaven Again
so
what does this have to do with today
well most Scholars agree that this is
probably just a myth but that's not the
point
the point is that people believe deeply
in Hassan and his vision for the world
and we're willing to sacrifice their
lives for it
he gave them a sense of meaning and
purpose during a time of great
uncertainty
a purpose which you communicated using
the best tools of his day
and that is what brings us to video
games
video games are already the world's
dominant form of entertainment they're
three times larger than the entire
Global film and music industry is
combined
every year the top streamers on Twitch
receive on average twice as many views
as the biggest Hollywood movies and
collectively we spend twice as much time
watching and playing video games as we
do using all other forms of social media
combined
that's a lot of eyeballs
game sales are huge but the real action
is in in-game economies where people
spend over 130 billion dollars a year
buying and selling virtual goods online
everything from outfits to avatars to
vehicles to weapons to dances to
architecture to music to access Live
Events and more
haven't even mentioned nft or web3 but
these hopefully will become the
infrastructure that drives this going
forward
so if you're wondering what the
metaverse looks like
this is it
the reason games are so successful is
because they provide a deep sense of
Engagement community and purpose
yes we use them to escape and to
entertain and that's okay but at their
best they speak to some of our Primal
social and psychological needs from
feeling effective
to achieving our goals to belonging to a
group to working for something bigger
than yourself
describing his experience in a top World
of Warcraft Guild the player winsy once
wrote it felt so amazing
thinking back it was probably the most
intense positive emotional experience of
my life
not my kid being born
not getting married
my mind was convinced we were in a war
against an insurmountable foe
and we won
you can probably see where I'm going
with this
although he later went on to regret the
amount of time he spent online
Gamers develop a deep sense of
commitment to a shared narrative world
a world which provides for them in a way
that Real World jobs and relationships
often do not
and this is already the world that our
children live in
the only thing that my son and daughter
want for their birthdays are Skyblocks
coins and digital emotes for their
characters
most of their social time outside of
school is spent hanging out in game with
their friends
my son Teo he's already flipping nfts to
in his words get rich as quickly as
possible so he can take care of us when
the World falls apart
thanks Dale appreciate that
that's why I think games are going to be
one of the driving forces of tomorrow's
culture
but if that's the game's part
what about the Colts part
well I'm sure we could all agree that
the coming years are going to be
interesting to say the least
from climate change Mass migration
pandemics
job loss and now War
the future feels terrifying for many
people
and this is having a tremendous impact
on our Mental Health
one-third of all U.S undergraduates
surveyed report having moderate to
severe anxiety
their rates of suicidal thinking and
severe depression doubled over the last
decade or so
and covet didn't help
but it's not just the us either
two-thirds of those surveyed in a study
of 17 different countries reported that
they thought their children were going
to grow up poorer and not have
successful careers
in other words the world feels like it's
falling apart for a lot of people
and when Worlds fall apart people start
looking for answers wherever they can
find them
and charismatic leaders like Hassan have
always been happy to provide them and
their actions have shaped the course of
history from the Protestant Reformation
in the 16th century to the rise of new
religious movements in the 19th century
every era of social change historically
has been followed by a wave of new
Believers and fanatical Behavior
is just the most recent example
and while each generation's cults look
different and the definition of a cult
is certainly Up For Debate they do share
general characteristics
the first is that they inspire a sense
of higher purpose often through a lens
of good versus evil where you are the
hero that creates a sense of passion or
commitment that seems insane or
irrational to The Outsider
and the second is that they adopt the
form of and use the tools of the
dominant organizations of their day
from the church
to the corporation
the social media Network
to our subject for today
the metaverse
so what happens when you mix billions of
people looking for meaning
Safety and Security
with widespread Virtual Worlds
crypto economies and gaming culture
the answer I believe is game cults
large-scale social movements
powered by extreme or bizarre beliefs
birthed in Virtual Worlds driven by game
Dynamics but with real world consequence
the future it's about to get weird
we can already see examples of this all
around us we just haven't had a name for
it yet
softer versions look like BTS stands
swarming Donald Trump rallies online but
more extreme versions look like
hezbollah's own custom-made video game
called Special Forces designed to
recruit young people and train them to
kill their enemies
white nationalist groups are hosting
Call of Duty tournaments online to
attract followers and there are Roblox
games where you can drive your car
through black lives matter protesters or
assume the role of Kyle Rittenhouse and
shoot anti-fascist protesters
and there are many other examples but
all of them are wrapped in a layer of
Discord servers and YouTube channels and
podcasts that acts as a funnel to draw
you deeper into a web of extremism and
radical Behavior
what starts on the screen no longer
stays on the screen
on is a perfect example of this what
started on 4chan and Facebook mutated
into a live-action role-playing group
for Evangelical militants and ended up
as an anti-vaccination campaign
before you know it we have a million
excess deaths from covid in the United
States and a political landscape far
Stranger than anything we've ever seen
same is going to be true for games
first you're a player
then you're a fan
soon you're in a clan
and before you know it you're invading
the capital
so I'm a futurist
and there's a saying with futurists that
your job is not to just predict the
automobile but to predict the traffic
jams
so what might this look like in 10 or 20
years when widespread augmented and
virtual reality means thriving crypto
economies and a generalized crisis of
meaning
well in the future games are going to be
everywhere they're going to move from
our screens and onto the streets around
us
hundreds of millions if not billions of
people will be buying selling making and
trading virtual goods online
they're going to assume roles as
characters follow quests and get real
world money for in-game performance
guilds corporations and clans will form
around them they might start offering
salaries paying benefits and providing
real world services like education or
health care or even security
people's entire lives we built around
their characters and their stories
particularly if things get really bad
and those stories will come to dominate
popular culture and politics
now thankfully not all of them
will be harmful but some will be
violently Evangelical in their nature
it's got me thinking there must be a
better way that we can use these
Dynamics
to heal instead of harm
so I started thinking what might this
look like
how can we explore possible futures for
positive game Cults so here are just
three examples I came up with a few
friends consider druidica a
minecraft-like nature game designed to
restore damaged ecosystems and preserve
indigenous knowledge
or perhaps walk about
arrest-like Survival game for refugees
designed to encourage skill sharing
interdependence and mutual Aid linked to
scriptural messages of Tolerance and
compassion
or perhaps Temple a pray to earn game
linked to a network of
non-denominational meditation spaces
where players can perform coordinated
acts of care to level up on the good
works board a kind of decentralized
Church of kindness powered Maybe by holy
coin
clear that
something like this is coming
the question is what can we do about it
now
as we've learned from social media
technological fixes and Regulatory
restrictions will only go so far
and in the attention economy of
political priorities game Cults are
clearly quite low but that's okay it
means we still have time to do something
about them
that's why I think that everyone from
policy makers to players
to game designers and Gamers should be
having a conversation about what this
means right now
if you are a media company
you should be
seeing how talking to experts in
radicalization
if you were a game company you should be
speaking to those who don't understand
gaming Dynamics in the community
surround them if you're a church or a
religious institution you should be
understanding how people use these tools
to build beliefs and what they're
believing and finally perhaps most
importantly if you're a parent you
should be playing games with your kids
to understand the world that they're
growing up in and to have a conversation
with them about the role that they might
play in it
someone's going to connect these dots
the question is
who is going to be our modern day Hassan
and will the games of tomorrow be games
of subjugation and domination
or inspiration and liberation
it's really up to us
thank you
[Applause]